hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to don't starve together
with Bob hi say hi for definitely the
first time Bob hi welcome to the very
first steps up man we're just gonna play
we're not gonna this this is gonna go
perfectly the hell you just rambled on
about I totally agree yeah it's like
that the multiplayer don't starve what
did we say before or not say but what
did have we already said is what I don't
know because I'm gonna edit this and
it's gonna be an amalgamation of horror
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm able to play this with Bob we've
been waiting a long time blah blah blah
we're bad at games but here we are again
oh we oh we have been waiting a long
time to do a series where it's just the
two of us playing Ellis because I've
been doing a lot of series with Wade
because Wade has been doing on YouTube
for a while now and we did mention this
before but may have been cut but I
wanted to mention again that it's it's
really surreal to me to realize that
Bob's channel has only existed for like
what four months five five five months
yeah cuz oh I'm starving to death that's
good he blew my mind earlier just like
with the idea that we have been playing
drunk minecraft for like two and a half
or three years now like is that it is
it's crazy to think I mean you're first
the first charity livestream that I
helped you with was probably one of the
first times I was like in a video with
you yeah that would have been I don't
even I don't even know like a long time
ago yeah what was even the first one
about that we did together I know the
first one that I did was for child's
play but I yeah totally was it American
Cancer Society because that brings them
no no that was later that was later that
was back when I had my apartment this is
still back when I was I my mom says well
I got back in history here explore
dummies that I never though
talk about again yeah yeah I can't
remember we've done so many is like
totally blanking I should know this Wow
what what did I look terrible in front
of millions of people 400 it's but the
number of years it's not even like the
number of times you've done it the
number of years that you've been doing
streams with with me without me with you
know yeah it's everywhere
crazy yeah it's totally cool but we're
here again and we get to play a game for
you guys and we get to show you how good
we are at games because I've played this
a lot
someone has even made a mod about this
game for me in this game and they're
gonna add Bob and wait in it at least
that's a rumor I don't know if that's
official I have heard that the marquee
mod team it's a team now it's going to
be adding in Wade and myself and
yamimash think that I hate Yami now just
cuz I haven't played video with him it's
cuz like when I'm in LA he's in the UK
and our schedules are totally different
in a hurry for like nine hours apart or
something right honey it's a shame when
I wake up he's going to bed or something
and he like already stays up way later
than he should so he's on the opposite
schedule of the opposite schedule so
just counterintuitive but I want to play
with him again soon like don't think
I've forgotten about yamimash this is
that Jack never sleeps
so I every every time I ever look at my
skype uh when I'm like bored or I'm just
trying to avoid doing all the homework
I'm supposed to be doing bad he's always
just out there just waiting to chat I'll
leave a message and he's just like Oh
Jack you should like have some fun or
yeah I don't think you go on vacation or
he's a crazy man
I think Jack is like an experimental
Irish experiment where they're cloning
multiple versions of the same guy to
make them the most typical Irishman
possible of being loud and bombastic and
loving to drink I'm not saying words
right but you know what I mean oh and
you share with me your extreme knowledge
of shovels and family things yes
stick and you've taken rock and you back
them together until you actually over
here is the first area of the fields
which is where we're actually gonna find
rocks and stuff so I can't make a
pickaxe you can't go through you yeah I
know that I know I know that so that's
good I can use that Hey look go bash it
with your face your robot bastard
where's the up there oh there's two
rocks it's rock heaven over here make a
pickaxe you lazy pizza okay there it is
it yep good job yeah yeah I got a
pickaxe and now you can break rocks and
you're gonna get real bored soon of
breaking rocks holy crap I'm at capacity
I really can't see we're gonna camp out
here actually what we're gonna do what
we're gonna do is I'm gonna be your
guide I have that torch and I'm gonna
use this torch to be able to guide your
way through the darkness why do I build
the science machine hang on do you have
enough stuff to build a science machine
I need one gold and one more rock okay
they have a butt load of logs pick up my
rocks we need to go find as we need to
find different type of rock that
actually has gold that's not like a gold
vein in it yeah it's like a gold rock or
something like that so we is this really
dangerous dangerous you should jump
right into it go around Hey
I see you're still breaking me up okay
sorry where the hell I'm in the dark
that's bad where is Oh clay
entertainment just responded to me to
give me a baby key oh I didn't say I
didn't say who gave me a beta key oh my
god I got to look this up hands are very
important
cuz he gave me a beta key totally
totally free I got a good shot oh yeah
yeah he saw me an email I think his name
is Anthony one second link you'll find
it because they got a oh god I don't
ah can i all tablet destroy everything
oh there we go
won't that probably destroy everything
everything is probably terribly wrong
right now so just bear with me I'm gonna
I'm gonna get it hang on is it okay
turn your torch off at state time okay
hang on cuz number two go find some
racks his name is okay I'm back I'm back
everybody is everything okay okay good
all systems engaged his name is Andrew
Kim so thank you Andrew Kim he didn't
ask for me to shout out anything extra
than that buddy gave me a free don't
starve key so thank you very much for
being awesome you are a cool guy yes
thank you
I I just got so excited when I I had a
friend
Oh what is this then what I found a
skeleton yeah he's it mine free shovel
Wow why was there a dead person but yeah
I just happened to have a friend
messaged me with the key for this and I
was just like oh my god I gotta play
that game right now mark let's play the
game yeah and then mark didn't have the
keys oh so what I did is I lever down my
entire fanbase and basically bang
someone named me please accorded his
fans yes that's exactly what I do all
day every day cuz you guys love me right
yay
I think okay back to the game we
survived our first night Oh enjoy go
this way now right yes we need to find a
rock with gold in it and what we have so
far just regular rocks now I don't know
if you press em you'll open up your map
and they'll show you where you've been
where you're going so this path here
leads up more into this grassland area
is there a certain locale where we're
gonna really find the rock surface sorry
I got distracted oh my god Oh poop
I am like really full of stuff I know we
need to find things it's a walking cane
do I don't know it guess helps you go
faster but I'm gonna pick up so much
poop here's a flashback we were talking
about this before when we work with when
things didn't happen about poop and
about Buffalo why are we talking about
that no I don't have this stuff that
comes out of our mouths I'm gonna make
myself a little hat nice hat you miss
you robot man are you trying to be a
real boy like Pinocchio I'm a real boy
oh god please don't talk again
I got a walking cane is that your
character's voice I'm a real boy I'm a
robot
Oh your impression skills are incredible
I know yes over the three years that
you've been doing imprinted it's really
gone up I mean I don't know if I was
doing impressions the whole time oh I
would like to think so
mm-hmm don't know what that means but
I'd still like okay that's spider nest
yeah no I think it would be really
prudent if we did not go anywhere near
that I just haven't a sneaking suspicion
yeah something about that also tells me
that going towards that means bad Hey
look a suspicious dirt pile let me dig
it up hey you know it's an animal track
it doesn't do much for us but we can
play animal tracks yeah why haven't we
found a gold vein yet what's this
suspicious turd pile Oh
probably another animal track yeah
animal track it's pointing a different
direction you got to go the direction
that the pause okay I've never done this
before so I don't know if this is good
or bad are we we're currently tracking
something that's gonna totally murder us
probably but you never know until you
try so just that's a that's a Brian
Regan punchline if I recall it doesn't
end well for the guy that says that oh
man Egham trail says end of trail well
poop where's the monster I don't know I
was so looking forward to an epic battle
yeah I guess not either way we still
need to find this gold vein because we
actually need to build a base what's
very important and what I never did was
build a central base they even returned
to and then you gather the supplies in
the area and then you build off of there
and that allows whoo-hoo what is that
it says attack I should around wait if I
have a torch won't it be afraid of the
torch keep I'm cutting it okay whoa
jumps jump it jumps it comin Oh George
and and zigzag kill serpentine oh wait
really we're in the middle of the pit we
need to build a fire in the middle of
the pit and then it won't come near
because it's fraid of real fire oh it's
afraid of fire this is our land now you
back off okay good I got this yes I got
this I'm gonna help oh I am running what
do you think I'm doing this was a
terrible
are going there okay this was a terrible
idea why do we do this I was doing fine
on my own I don't know why introducing
you into this made me do horribly oh
wait a minute
I did horribly by myself - hmm all right
I got a torch yeah yeah I think we're
saying oh I think I'm actually out of
materials I can't carry anymore so yeah
okay now that wait so well should we
shall we fire should we make a fire I
think we should you know this is a great
start - yeah okay - fires twice the
light can't possibly be worse than one
fire can ya no of course now I know it's
totally fine this this this is our base
whether we like it or not I broke my
damn shovel God why do we have two
shovels if it exceeds my carrying
capacity obviously I don't want to pick
it up oh okay so anyway we're still
alive for the night and we're done with
this episode so thank you all so much
for watching check out my don't starve
series I also check out our rust series
it goes about as good as this is going
so please watch it any final words Bob
oh we're just so good at this game I
can't believe it I were just Naturals
man so thanks again everybody and as
always we will see you in the next video
[Music]
hey hey hey hey hey hey go away